[Música]
porque con este segundo invitado al día
vamos a hablar de las consecuencias
económicas del cambio climático tanto en
el mundo como en nuestra región de
américa latina y el caribe por supuesto
para hablar de este tema económico las
consecuencias del cambio climático
económicamente hablando nos acompaña
también nuestra periodista de economía
daniel langdon danny bienvenidos
nuevamente gracias raúl puedes analizar
este tema porque muchas veces vemos el
clima como alejado de la economía
alejado de nuestros bolsillos y nos
vamos a dar cuenta de que no es así es
tan cercano que nos da miedo daniela
saludamos a santiago lorenzo jefe de la
unidad de economía del cambio climático
de la cepal santiago gracias por estar
con nosotros esta mañana directo américa
de france 24 muy buen día
gracias raúl buendía gusto estar aquí
santiago como lo estábamos conversando
antes de presentarlo demos un contexto
digamos para situar a nuestros
televidentes las personas que nos ven
que tan cercano digamos y que están
directamente relacionado hasta el cambio
climático con nuestra economía con
nuestros bolsillos y bueno justo en los
bolsillos estamos viendo cómo están
subiendo los precios de los alimentos
son distintas las causas pero el cambio
climático está presente por ejemplo
tenemos
sequías en varios lugares de brasil para
nada la cuenca del paraná para brasil
paraguay y bolivia
tenemos sequías aquí en chile donde está
la cepal tenemos 14 años de de sequía
para que prácticamente en la zona
central que está afectando obviamente
los cultivos
en europa hoy en día con rosell la
intensa ola de calor que está sucediendo
se está previendo la pérdida o la
disminución de cosechas este año tanto
en francia que es uno de los países que
más producto agrícola tiene seguramente
va a tener unas cosechas mucho más bajas
en eeuu también se espera un poco lo
mismo después en los fenómenos extremos
muchas veces las heladas caen antes de
tiempo y también se deben cosechas
entonces la
particularmente la cadena de valor de
los de los alimentos está siendo ya
afectada
enormemente y después obviamente todos
los desastres generan presiones fiscales
y por tanto si bien ya sabemos ya lo
hemos visto por la pandemia que los
países de américa latina tienen un
espacio fiscal muy reducido no tenemos
presupuesto para atender emergencias de
la manera o necesidades ya históricas de
la manera que quisiéramos
con los desastres se puede se requieren
fondos para la activación de medidas de
emergencia y de 'soy de sustento y apoyo
a las poblaciones y por ejemplo los
huracanes en el caribe es la
temporada de 2021 fue la tercera más
intensa en toda la historia y en con
muchos daños en vidas humanas siendo la
propiedad y hay que intervenir y eso
cuesta cuesta dinero al fisco que tiene
más presiones para para para recabar más
los impuestos y se
limita el presupuesto para otras cosas
estos son ejemplos el señor lorenzo
cuáles son esos países de la región que
es que son más afectados a donde el
cambio climático está golpeando con más
fuerza y va a haber un mayor impacto
económico y sobre qué clase de cultivos
para que también sepamos qué es lo que
tenemos en riesgo a futuro
pues básicamente toda américa latina
está catalogada como de las zonas con
junto con áfrica y el sudeste asiático
son de las regiones más vulnerables al
cambio climático
américa latina' contribuya ha
contribuido con menos del 10 por ciento
de las dimensiones históricamente o sea
no somos de los causantes del fenómeno
sin embargo somos estamos en la primera
línea de los afectados todas las
regiones del caribe y centroamérica son
particularmente
vulnerables tanto por los
fenómenos externos con los huracanes
como también hay sequía se descubrió
sólo hay un contraste entre las lluvias
torrenciales y los vientos de huracán y
después temporadas de sequía prolongadas
en estas mismas zonas
aquí en chile por ejemplo los cultivos
por ejemplo la uva que se está detrás de
la industria del vino que son de los
principales generadores de ingresos del
país están y están previendo moverse
hacia el sur muchos muchos viñedos
porque la zona central como decía está
en plena sequía en las zonas del sur de
brasil que también son agrícolamente
importantes también están en
experiencias experimentando este tipo de
cambio de mudanza de hacia la ansiedad
la seca del secano y eso está de hecho
no yo no diría que hay un país que se
escape todos en méxico por ejemplo el
norte hoy en día sufre es la segunda
ciudad más importante del país con mucha
industria que es monterrey está
sufriendo problemas de agua por la
sequía y eso está afectando inclusive la
industria que no es agrícola entonces
porque no tienen agua para trabajar
entonces estamos viendo que todo el
continente está impactado también en
santiago estamos hablando precisamente
este desplaza desplazamiento que se da
en los países no para debido a estos
climas extremos como esto también afecta
digamos la economía de esas personas
como eso también afecta la economía del
estado que posiblemente tiene que
subsidiar a ayudar a estas personas que
se están desplazando porque no pueden
vivir en sus territorios a causa del
clima extremo y también como esto
amenaza digamos la producción de
alimentos tan importantes
y bueno efectivamente estamos hablando
de impactos en la agricultura en las
industrias y esos impactos se traducen
finalmente en empleos empresas que ya no
son viables en una región por cuestiones
de cambio climático tienen que ir
cerrando cuando no se cambian y si se
cambian o cierran significa directamente
para miles de personas una nueva
situación de vida que significa
posiblemente que tendrán que emigrar
posiblemente tendrán que adaptarse a
otro tipo de vida eso definitivamente va
más allá de la primera la pregunta
original del impacto en el bolsillo es
decir el cambio climático va a cambiar
nuestras sociedades lenta y
apresuradamente vamos a tener 22
velocidades porque así hacen también
climático hay zonas donde el cambio es
mucho más drástico y hay zonas donde es
más lento y vamos a tener mucho
movimiento social y hay riesgos todos
estos
la escases de agua las migraciones todo
eso genera tensiones sociales genera
conflictos entonces no es una cuestión
de que de repente vaya haber un colapso
en los sistemas que pudieran suceder
todavía no se prevé algo así podría
suceder si vamos a temperaturas más
grandes hoy en día la trayectoria global
está hacia 3.2 3.6 grados de
calentamiento global
en la zona más o menos salga a salvo
para la humanidad es 1.5 si acaso 2
grados de temperatura la 2100 y vamos a
una trayectoria mucho más grande que
puede generar problemas mayores pero si
logramos controlar que no estamos
haciendo lo necesario para controlar ese
calentamiento eso es una cosa que hay
que remarcar si logramos controlar aún
así vamos a tener tensiones vamos a
tener conflictos y eso repercute en
gobernabilidad repercute en gasto
público efectivamente para para hacer
esas redes de esa salvedad social
digamos